puis voté pour la liste europe écologie
les verts yve menée par yannick jadot
c'est mettre un bulletin vert pour élire
un député vert keira siéger au groupe
verts au parlement européen pour
immobiliser les moyens de l'europe
contre le réchauffement climatique
c'est un grand plan d'investissement de
100 milliards par an pour assurer la
transition écologique voter pour la
liste europe écologie les verts c'est
voter pour la possibilité d'adopter des
secondes à un grand traité
environnementale qui met la question
environnementale écologique ou dessus de
toutes les autres pour être à la hauteur
de l'enjeu de réchauffement climatique
voter pour la liste europe écologie les
verts c'est voter pour réconcilier les
femmes - et la fin du monde
[Musique]
l'urgence est telle que il ne sera pas
possible d'agir efficacement à 60
millions d'habitants
nous avons besoin de l'espace européen
pour agir efficacement contre le
réchauffement climatique pour mobiliser
tous les moyens qui nous permettent de
sortir à la fois du nucléaire et des
énergies fossiles à 350 millions de
citoyens engagés à 350 millions de
consommateurs engagés nous pouvons
inverser la tendance et réussir le plus
grand défi qui est de préserver cette
planète en bon état de préserver la
biodiversité et d'offrir un avenir à nos
jeunes
[Musique]
nous souhaitons demain au sein du
parlement européen que le groupe le plus
important des l'écho des écologistes
participent à imposer la sortie
immédiate du claudie glyphosate et plus
généralement nous souhaitons une
agriculture qui se passe des pesticides
parce que l'agriculture c'est notre
alimentation et parce que nous avons
droit à une alimentation saine sans
pivot hâte parce que la politique
agricole commune c'est le budget le plus
important de l'union européenne c'est
40% mer pour la france c'est 9 milliard
ces 9 milliards doit participer à la
conversion de l'agriculture qui a nous
permettent de nourrir de manière saine à
offrir des revenus décents aux
agriculteurs et à préserver leur santé
en réalité
en réalité la sortie du glyphosate et
des pesticides est bon pour les
agriculteurs bon pour la biodiversité
bon pour les citoyens il ne manque que
la volonté politique pour y arriver
p
[Musique]